jared goff the rams quarterback just a
week after sean mcvay downplayed the
concept of a contract extension for
jared goff before the start of the
season jared goff has a contract
extension before the start of the season
it's a four-year extension worth 134
million that's a new money average of
33.5 million tying him with oh aaron
rodgers what do you think of that just
first and foremost jared goff makes as
much as aaron rodriguez i don't you hurt
it's insane i mean
i've argued this all spring right i
don't know why the next guy up always
has to out do the the next guy i just
don't get that you know there's certain
guys that like we've said you know they
don't deserve to be paid on the
defensive side like aaron donald or
khalil mack but yet they're going to
make that much money you know same thing
with some of these guys on offense yeah
and especially the quarterback position
it just seems whoever's up next gets
more and that makes the market go crazy
and to me that makes the quarterbacks
get more money than they deserve and
then the wealth doesn't get to spread as
much but
i mean i mean the ramps had to do this
they did their pressure was on the
perception he's the franchise
quarterback well here's but here's why
here's the problem right when people
like us criticize jared goff when we say
i'd rather have dak prescott than jared
goff when we say jared goff is a product
of sean mcvay's system right because we
have so much faith in sean mcveigh as a
coach yes and mcvay responds to that by
going over the top all in right how goff
is the guy and he's really taking
ownership of the team and he's this and
he's that
you're basically filling out the check
at that point yes
and would bill belichick ever go on and
on and on about any of his players no
because when you do that you back
yourself into the corner where you've
got to pay they did have to do it yeah
because their reaction to the criticism
of jared goff set them up for that now
at 33 and a half million a year new
money right look that that's that's
that's a big deal it puts him at number
three tied with aaron rodgers behind
russell wilson and ben roethlisberger so
he didn't
eclipse everybody right russell wilson
but he's still up there in that
conversation and it was smart for them
to do it now because dak prescott may be
in that same territory and he hasn't
been to a super bowl right although i'd
still take sorry i'd take sorry jared
i'd take goff over or it takes place
yeah but patrick mahomes is looming yeah
and when patrick wilhelm stretches that
rubber band to 40 million a year or more
you're gonna wish you had done jared
goff's deal that i think was the main
impetus to doing this now because if you
don't do it now then there's a chance
mahomes goes first and once my homes
goes the market goes hayward it would
explode i agree with you there yeah i
mean hey i think jared goff again i
don't think he was looking to break the
record i do believe him and the fact
that he wanted to do something you know
reasonable okay i'll give him that
certainly i do think the right thing
it's a lot of reasonable well 33 and a
half million
that buys you a lot of reasons it does
it certainly does they're back to do a
corner though they are i mean from
everything not only the fact that the
talks of dak prescott's contract are
going the guy that was picked after
jared goff his contract is done and
carson wentz okay it didn't look right
and then the the real fact of the nfl
perception becomes reality at some point
and the fans and the people that
surround the los angeles rams they think
he's a franchise big time quarterback
and you know of course i've argued that
i mean i think i you know i don't know
where i had him in my quarterback
ranking somewhere between 12 and 18
somewhere right around there okay i
think i had him at 18 or 19. that's
where i look at it he's not a franchise
quarterback to me in the aspect of he's
just going to carry your team when
things don't go well you know he's more
of a guy that you mentioned to me it's
always been mcveigh has to massage
massage the player a little bit he has
to formulate game plans early in the
game to make sure jared goff's in a good
rhythm where i would argue some of the
other quarterbacks were talking about
roethlisberger rogers uh russell wilson
you know brady
they just run a game plan and they say
you guys better just execute it it's
different in the rams there and that's
why i think there was a delay and i
think the rams probably didn't want to
pay him this early but the public
pressure and the scrutiny around the
situation and the fact that they were
always talking about it i think they
were backed into the corner and that's
why they do it sources close to me
telling me that you had jared goff at
number 19 right yeah i would feel better
about your rankings if you remembered
where the guys were well i said 18 or
19. yeah
well okay what do you mean you know what
like the alphabet these are your
quarterback rankings own them sims well
the top 10 i got for sure but it's i
wasn't sure about where i was or exactly
let me make this point right i talked
about this during the radio hour while
you were still in bed yeah the uh
the rams were paying jared goff 33.5
million yeah per year right cam newton
makes 20 million a year yeah it's insane
again insane insane and you take clearly
newton before goff clearly newton was in
your top six or seven yeah yes i think
he was eight right i mean he's he's a he
was eight for sure okay there you go
that's the way to do it
all right but he yes i mean you know cam
newton is a generational talent he's a
rare bird i mean the things he can do
again do not get quantified on a stat
sheet he is truly special that way and
it is insane from that standpoint and
that just you know tells you that the
carolina panthers gonna have to
renegotiate something with with uh with
with cam newton at some point but either
way i'll say this for the rams they got
their guy they've got a quarterback that
they feel like they can win with they
have built something special there in
los angeles mcveigh does have faith in
him and i think he probably still thinks
we haven't seen the best of jared goff
at this point yet he's still developing
and we'll see where it goes like like we
talked about last year he showed some
games last year where we went oh look at
him he's carrying the team for a quarter
right i mean whether it was the chiefs
game with some of the throws when he
just tore apart your vikings well when
you have anthony barr covering receivers
there's an issue right right but either
way he had some moments to give me hope
for the future to go oh this guy maybe
is one of those guys that can carry the
squad when things aren't good one last
point about cam newton because he gets a
lot of criticism yeah he's never said a
word about how underpaid he is and it is
insulting how underpaid he currently is
i mean yeah in relation right to other
right quarterbacks and maybe they're
handling it all quietly behind the
scenes but you know what i'd like to see
a new deal for cam newton get announced
before saturday of this week he deserves
it and i think we need to start banging
that drone yeah let's start banging all
right well we just started yeah let's
start it carolina pay the guide
sacrificed his life for you hi i'm mike
tarico and thanks for watching make sure
to hit subscribe for the latest news and
highlights from nbc sports